it's strange because like we're we're in
this moment and we're having a nice time
how is this wrong how does this not work
for everybody
[Music]
why isn't this something worth fighting
for why isn't this something we're
staying for
[Music]
I don't know I'm just one of those
people who hopes constantly
that maybe something
will spark for someone and they'll just
go oh this is worth figuring out and
sticking around because I don't know I
would look at it and think that
um
that's nice let's just put it there
Robert
it could make Christine feel like hey
this is worth staying for
[Music]
I believe God can
um
make miracles happen
I wonder if it's a game
you know when I look at days like this
when we're all together when we're
smiling and we're setting the crap aside
like why can't we do that why can't we
work on the things that we need to work
on between each other
we're not doing Justice to our family
and we're not doing you know Justice to
Ariella and Solomon and truly these
little ones who really need to have that
security a family
foreign
I'm devoted to you know doing what I
need to do I know that not everybody is
it feels like there's storms brewing in
the family I don't know what they mean I
don't know what the outcome will be
I personally am not very optimistic that
we'll see very many days like this did
you say the quiche is gluten-free the
quiche is gluten free yes Cody is not
one to hide his emotions though he's
more like gonna show you how he's
feeling and I think he's just super sad
and it's bittersweet he loves Isabel and
he hasn't spent enough time with her and
I think he's probably realizing that
foreign
this evening has gone off without a
hitch it's been wonderful and I think
Isabella's felt special
I'm just blue
Saul pull your britches up
we will never be there again if we
really go through this as Christine is
leaving is she really going to leave
I'm living in a delusional world where
I'm wishing that Christine wouldn't
leave
foreign